okay hi everyone okay so for today we're going to um you know I guess do a 180 from where we were on Tuesday and so today um I'm going to talk about um syntactic structure linguistic structure of human language sentences dependency passing and how well dependency and then how you go about building dependency paes so um we're um solidly inter linguistic Zone today um how many people in the audience have done a Linguistics class yay okay there's some people have done Linguistics classes okay great um and
for the rest of you well you know this is your chance to see a little bit of human language structure and if you like it you can enroll in a Linguistics class later on um yeah so oops so um you know so assignment two we handed out on Tuesday so in the second half of assignment two um what your job to do is to build a neural dependency paard using p torch um as you'll s we'll sort of come to later on really the bit that you have to build is just the machine learning bit of making decisions
and really we give you most of the rest of the new dependency paa but this is also then a chance to remind you that assignment two in that second half uses py torch one of the leading deep learning Frameworks um so if you're not familiar with that it'd be a really good idea to also go along to um the Friday pie torch tutorial um though we have tried to make assignment too so it's a fairly good place for learning pie torch as you go along um we'll say more soon about um final projects but you're
certainly already in encourage to come and meet with Tas or me about final projects and we're putting up information about the T so you can know more about them on um the office hours page okay so let's get straight into it and start looking at linguistic structure so um in in um thinking about linguistic structure of human languages there are two primary ways um that people have thought about it so one way is um using the idea that linguists normally call phrase structure which is then represented in terms of what um
computer scientists normally know as context free grammars so I'm going to spend a couple of minutes um going over that view of things but you know actually it's not the main one that I'm going to talk about in this class I'm going to spend most of this class talking about an alternative way of thinking about things called dependency grammars um there are actually some correspondences you can make between the two ways of thinking about things but I'm not going to go through into those
um here today so for the constituency grammar or phrase structure um version of things the way that you go about thinking about the structure of human languages is well there are words languages have lots of words hundreds of thousands of words but it seems like a lot of the words nearly all the words in fact fall into a few basic classes that represent their nature and how they behave in sentences so for words like the examples here we have nouns so cat is a noun door is a noun but you know something like Linguistics is also a
noun so we have nouns um and then we have other kinds of words so something like cuddly is an adjective a word that can modify nouns um and then we have theth for the the cuddly cat um the is sort of a slightly more complex one as to how to name um normally in modern Linguistics refer to words like that as a determiner you might also see the name article and when sometimes when people try to shoehorn um human language into eight part of speech categories that they say it's an adjective that doesn't
really behave like regular adjectives and then we have words like by or through or on and to and ones like that and so they're then prepositions right so we have these classes and with lots of words fitting into each class and so they're referred to conventionally as parts of speech but then once we've got words we start putting them into bigger units so the cuddly cat is some kind of unit and so it seems like this is a um explication of a noun cat and so this gets referred to as a noun phrase um and
then by the door well this is a phrase um but actually it has inside it this the door and that's a noun phrase but this bigger unit here of by the door is then a prepositional phrase and we can continue to build bigger units so inside you know this we have this phrase that we've already looked at with the noun phrase and a prepositional phrase but then we can have another noun phrase the cuddly cat and we can put them together and build a bigger noun phrase the cuddly Cat by the door and so to represent this you can
start to write um a phrase structure grammar or a context free grammar that represents what are the possibilities for building up sentences here in English those similar kinds of phrase structure grammars can be written for other languages so this is sort of starting to give you possible structures for a noun phrase so you can have a noun phrase just goes to a determiner followed by a noun but then as well as the cat and a dog you can have the large cats so you might say that okay rather than that I might want to have as a
better rule that a noun phrase goes to a determiner and optional adjective and then a noun if you think about it you can sort of have multiple adjectives so you can have the the large um green cat or something like that um so you can really get multiple adjectives that are heing and that sort of star the clean star says you can have lots of them um the large cuddly green cat um but then you can stick things after the now phrase so you can put these prepositional phrases like in a crate so we might also want to say that a noun
phrase can be Rewritten as a noun phrase followed by a prepositional phrase where a prepositional phrase um can be represented by preposition followed by a noun phrase and somewhere we're also going to want to represent our parts of speech membership so a determiner um can go to words like a or and an adjective can go to words like large cuddly or many other words that I'm not going to write down and a preposition can go to words like in on under Etc after that okay so now I've got a a little grammar here and this
little grammar here could sort of make everything I've gotten these sentences well actually can do this one too it can do the large barking one where there are multiple ones um but then if I start going Beyond these noun phrases and say think of sentences like talk to the cat or talk to the large cuddly dog by the door well now I've got here a verb talk and I've again got a preposition so I might um then have more rules that says I can have a verb phrase and the verb phrase can go to a verb and
then a prepositional phrase and then that could explain these two sentences as well and in this kind of way I can start to build up a grammar of the structure of English sentences as a context free grammar make sense yeah okay um and so that's um what is being quite commonly done in linguistics and elsewhere um okay uh yeah uh so let me just do that once more but behind in this one so one thing I can do here is say oh I have I'm going to look at this with its phrase structure and if I write it upside down
to give myself some space for later you know I could start um making a phrase structure that is of this sentence um and I'll start to run out of space but I can sort of start to make this phrase structure of the sentence so that's um phrase structure um but there's another form of representation that has been fairly widely used in linguistics and we're going and has been commonly used in NLP and we're going to use for the paes we built and that's dependency structure so dependency structure represents things
in a slightly different way it thinks about words that are the main word or head or something and then which words they take as modifiers or arguments so for look in the large crate in the kitchen by the door well this is um describing a looking command so that the head of the whole thing is looking um and then looking is taking one or more arguments or modifiers and well what the looking is saying here is well what you want to do is look in the large crate so we are looking in something and then
when what we're looking in is a crate and then the crate has some modifiers it's a large crate it's the large crate and then the crate um is also um placed somewhere it's placed in the kitchen so that in the kitchen is also modifying crate um and then we've got over here the by the door um well the by the door um is also modifying crate so we've also got a link down over to here and that gives us our piece of structure here which having filled that in makes me realize I actually got it wrong in when I was
doing the constituency representation whoopsie so I should get my CU in the constituency representation I made the kitchen by the door into a phrase that was actually wrong whoops bad me um so what I should have actually had um was we had another prepositional phrase that went to a noun phrase of in the kitchen and then both of those were coming off a bigger noun phrase like that whoopsie okay um I get it right most of the time okay but so this idea of um dependency structure is that we're sort of finding what is the
head word and then we're saying which things modify the headword and either of these represent ations we can be using um to sort of work out what the structure of sentences is in terms of which words go together and which words modify other words and so the basic idea is so when humans communicate we communicate in a linear stream right so that if it's um conventional writing systems it's a linear stream of words that you're reading if it's spoken language like you're understanding me
speaking right now it's not a linear stream of words it's a linear Sound Stream and you know like when people speak there aren't any you know there isn't white space between words when people speak you know occasionally people pause at the end of a clause or sentence or something but in general I'm just sort of speaking continuous words that run one into each other so that there's a a a linear sequence of sounds coming out my mouth um and you have to do all bit like that but the but if
you're then thinking oh gee um I can actually understand Chris talking then somehow you're taking that linear stream and you're turning it into a meaning where certain words are modifying other words and you have these bigger units um like constituents that are understanding the meaning of the sentence and so human listeners need to work out what modifies what to be able to understand sentences correctly and so similarly our models need to be able to understand sentence structure in order to be able to
interpret language correctly and so for what we're going to be doing for building dependency paes is we're going to be explicitly building a neural network model that says let's find the structure of these sentences um in way we actually move away from that later on because when we move into um Transformer language models they just take in the um sequence of words but actually inside the parameters of the newal network they recognizing and building the same kind of structural units and we'll talk about
that later in the class um to give you more of a sense of how um these you know understanding what modifies what is important for interpretation um here are a few funny examples from newspaper headlines and they're funny examples because you get um there sentences don't just have one way of interpreting them um when you have a sequence of words commonly in human languages sequence of words are ambiguous and it's relying on human interpretation of what makes sense and what goes together to work out how
to read them so here's a first example um scientists count whales from space um now that's um ambiguous and you can give this two possible readings so how can you give this um headline two possible readings yeah one is that they scien in space counting whales and the other one is that they're whales from in space yeah so one possibility is so we've got this prepositional phrase this is a prepositional phrase here one possibility is that this prepositional phrase is modifying or is the OB yeah it's
modifying whales um so they're whales from space and the other possibility is that it's the counting that's happening from space so the scientists are counting it from space okay so that corresponds to my two pictures here um so in one picture it's the counting that is happening from space um which is actually the right interpretation of what the article is about um but in the other interpretation we have space whales um and the and the scientists are counting the space whales that are arriving or something like that
and so then we have um the from space that are modifying the whales okay um so what we have here right is a prepositional phrase which comes after a noun phrase it's just a onew noun phrase here whales that's fine and then before that is a verb and so the thing so one place in English where you get a lot of ambiguities is from these prepositional phrases because whenever you get prepositional phrases and prepositional phrases are really common in English if you think about it whenever you get them like this it's
always ambiguous as to oops it's always amb uous as to what earlier thing in the sentence they dependent of um and so um you know you can sort of put in another prepositional phrase in the morning or something like that and so then the ambiguities just multiply and so the important thing to notice here about human language is human language is in synta I terms globally ambiguous right so in programming languages you have local ambiguities interpretation how many people have done a compilers class I
think very few these days anyone done a compilers class okay it looks like less people have done a compilers class than a Linguistics class that's interesting okay well I won't make too many analogies to compilers classes in you know when I was young you know that was still the old days kind CS curriculum where writing interpreters and compilers were seen as the main sta of Computer Science Education but no more I guess um yeah so um in programming languages you can have a local ambiguity but ambiguities are
always resolved right so we have simple rules and programming languages that else is um construed with the nearest if um you know it's a bit different in Python because it's indentation but you know There are rules that so there's never Global ambiguity in a programming language um and but human languages just aren't like that right that there's nothing that resolves which of these two readings is correct if I made it a bigger sentence that'd still be ambiguous you're just sort of meant to
read it and use context in your intelligence to decide um what's going on and so to take a a bigger but real example um this is the kind of boring sentence that you can read in the Wall Street Journal most mornings um the board approved its acquisition by Royal Trustco limited of Toronto for $27 a share at its monthly meeting um so um what you can see in this sentence is we've got a verb and then we've got a noun phrase and then what are what after that we have four prepositional phrases
in a row okay so what do these prepositional phrases modify so what does by Royal Trustco limited modify the acquisition right so it's the acquisition by Royal Trust Co then of Toronto modifies so it's Royal Trustco limited of Toronto um so yeah later on prepositional phrases can also modify earlier prepositional phrases or at least the noun phrase inside them World Trustco limited okay for $27 a share is back to modifying the acquisition okay at its monthly meeting is is yeah it's the approval so
it's gone way back up to there right um but you know um yeah so you know so if you start having sentences um with a whole bunch of prepositional phrases like this you can start getting more and more ambiguities of attachment I mean you don't get the full you don't get the sort of full free choice factorial number of attachment points because there is a restriction that these dependencies don't cross um so once you've gone back further you have to stay equally far back or go even
back further back again but nevertheless so the number of readings you get is Catalan series which is a series you see in a whole bunch of other places if you've done any graph Theory or anything like that you know if you're doing triangulations you get um cat alarms because you get the same property um that things don't cross so it's an exponentially growing um sequence of possible readings and so it quickly gets very big so I think when you you've got four prepositional phrases you get 13
readings and if you have five you 27 and you know grows up from there so you get a lot of ambiguities but the crucial thing to notice is you know human beings read sentences like this every morning or at least people who work in banking do while you know having their Corn Flakes and you know they their brain doesn't explode trying to think about the 13 different readings and which one is correct right we just sort of do this as we go along and it's sort of obvious um okay let's just do a couple more
examples of where we get ambiguities in um in human language so a different one you get is coordination scope ambiguity so shuttle veteran and longtime Nas executive Fred Gregory appointed the board how is this sentence ambiguous it mean two people or one person yeah so there can either be one person Fred Gregory and they're both a shuttle veteran and a NASA executive or it can be that there are two people there's a shuttle veteran and um there's a longtime Nessa executive Fred Gregory okay yeah so and we'd be kind of
capturing those by having extra grammar rules where a noun phrase can go to a noun phrase a conjunction and a noun phrase um but then another another thing that you get in English is um apposition so you can have a noun phrase that's a descriptive noun phrase of another noun phrase like a name um you know the author Fred Gregory or something like that um um saying the word English again I I I meant to comment um so you know I'm I'm only going to give English examples here um in different languages
you don't get all the same ambiguities um so if you're familiar with same Chinese um you might have thought about the prepositional phrase example of wait a minute we don't have that one because the prepositional phrase modifying the verb would appear before the verb and the object noun would be afterward so it would be completely unambiguous and that's true um but you know that doesn't mean that Chinese is unambiguous Chinese has lots of very bad ambiguities and um yeah it's just that
you know different languages have different syntactic structures okay um here's so sometimes um in English especially when you're sort of in a more written form rather than having an explicit con coordination word you can just sort of use ju to position with a comma um to have the idea of coordination so here's a um fun example um from the first Trump Administration of how we can have a coordination scope ambiguity um doctor no heart cognitive issues um right so again this is the same kind of coordination scope
ambiguity that it can either be kind of no hard and cognitive issues being conjoined together like that or else it could be that it's no heart or cognitive issues being conjoined um together like that you make the choice um okay uh let's see oh this this is this is my risque one for a different kind of ambiguity um trigger warning um students get firsthand job experience so this one is also um an ambiguity um you know as to whether you're having the um the firsthand and then both the job and the
firsthand a modifying experience or there's this other reading if you have a smutty mind that might come to you um okay one more fun one okay mutilated body washes up on Rio Beach to be used for Olympics beach volleyball okay so what are what are the two possible readings of this sentence you know these are real examples from quality newspapers um okay what are the two readings of this sentence yeah so we've got so so the here we have one of these infinitival um so infinitival verb phrase to be used for Olympic beach
volleyball and for these as well you know they kind of have the same effect as prepositional phrases um that they can can modify um different things um so it can either be the Rio Beach that's going to be used for the Olympic beach volleyball or it's going to be the mutilated body that gets used for the um beach volleyball okay um yeah so the so these are the kind of ways in which we sort of want to use um the structure of the sentence to understand what they're meaning we also use it in lots of sort
of just sort of M practical ways um when we're building various kinds of natural language processing systems so you know a kind of thing that people often in Practical systems do is that they want to get out facts of various kinds so for people who um do stuff with bioinformatics that they commonly want to get out things like protein protein interaction facts and so commonly you can get those kind of facts out by looking for patterns so you know have a verb of interacts that's going to be indicating um an interaction
pattern and well it's going to be taking arguments so it's going to be taking a subject and interacts with the prepositional argument and so that will be um an interaction that kisy whatever that is interacts with sass a but in this case the Sass a is coordinated with the kai a and the kai B so it's also going to end up interacting with those two other things as well and so you can use the sort of sentence structure patterns of a dependency PA to be getting out the kind of um facts and
events that you're interested in for something like an um event understanding system and people you know do these kind of anal analyses over biomedical texts to build up the kind of structured databases of known protein protein interactions and things of that sort okay so linguistic structure is useful um and it's syntactically very ambiguous and so you should think of humans as active interpreters that are using their contextual knowledge both of earlier stuff in the text knowledge of the world around them how the world
Works to work out the right um structure yeah so now I want to go on um and show you a bit more about sort of dependency grammars which is what we're going to be using so for dependency syntax that it postulates that you can capture the structure of a sentence by having these sort of asymmetric um dependent relations which we might just call arrows which are going from heads to dependence so here the sentence is um bills on ports and immigration were submitted by Senator Brownback Republican of Kansas and we sort of
picking out heads um and then we got um things that depend on them that modify them um yeah so if you're on the um video audience and you are educated in the United States and you're over the age of 50 um or if you happen to go to one of those kind of private schools where they also teach Latin um you might have seen sentence diagramming um so read Kellogg um sentence diagramming was something that was actually very widespread um in American Education um which really was a it was a some it was
really dependency grammar was a sort of a somewhat quirky form of dependency grammar where you had to write lines at different angles and stuff like that but basically you're writing sort of heads and their dependence underneath them with different funny shaped lines um it also was dependency grammar okay um so this is the start of a dependency grammar but just like the the funny angled lines of sentence diagramming normally people want to add some more information than that um and so most commonly um that the arrows are
then typed by giving the name of some grammatical relation so something can be the noun subject or an oblique or an appositional modifier or a case mark or things like that um and um I I'm just trying to give you the idea of dependency grammars I'm not expecting you to master all of these names and ways of doing things um and you know there are different systems of deciding what's heads and dependence and not all the details are important what you should get into your head is just sort
of the basic idea of what one of these does and some sense of oh it should be at the phrase level it should be representing what's modifying what so we do actually ask some questions um on the assignment and so for the cases like the prepositional phrase what is it modifying you should be able to give the right answer to that okay um yeah um okay so uh this is just a little bit more um vocabulary so yeah we have these or dependencies and so I'm going to say that they connect between a head and a dependent but sometimes
people use other words like governor and modifier and things like that um and so dependencies are generally taken and will be taking them as forming a tree so you've got something that's connected as cyclic and has a single root to it so our single root is the top of the sentence here um so um dependency so although what you see most often these days either in a Linguistics class or when you get taught CS 103 at Stanford or computer science what you see there is normally context free grammars or phase structure grammars I
mean really you know it is dependency grammars that have the really long history so really the predominant way of representing the structure of human languages throughout human history is dependency grammar um so who linguist um Herald as the first dependency grammarian or really the first person who tried to write the grammar of a human language period was panani so panani was working with Sanskrit um panani lived so long ago that actually people don't really know when he lived I mean he lived somewhere between about
the 4th and 8th Century before the common ER but really no one knows when um but you know he lived um sort of up in part of actually what's now Afghanistan um and um for Motivated for largely religious reasons um he said about developing a grammar of Sanskrit and the way he represented the syntax of Sanskrit was using a dependency grammar um so there was a lot of work on grammar in Arabic in the first Millennium they used dependency grammars um in contrast um the idea of sort of having context free
grammars that's really really recent so the first work on um phrase structure grammars dates to the 40s and then was sort of um canonicalized by the work of Chomsky in the 1950s yeah so um a fact for the computer science part of people in the audience so computer dear computer scientists if you know about Chomsky computer scientists normally know two things about Chomsky one is they hate on the Chomsky hierarchy that they were forced to learn um in CS 103 or equivalent classes and the second one is he's a
very left politician um but um if I only deal with the first one of the two now um the Chomsky hierarchy was not invented either to torture Elementary computer scientists um or um to explain fundamental facts about formal language Theory the Chomsky hierarchy was actually invented in thinking about human languages because at that time and in stuff that's come more often it was commonly the case that um people were modeling human languages with um Regular finite so finite State grammar equivalent mechanisms and Chomsky wanted
to argue that that was a completely inadequate um formalism to represent um the complexity of human language and so it was in the context of arguments about human language was why he developed um the Chomsky hierarchy okay um yeah so anyway uh that's enough of the history of that um here's my uh picture of part of panan grammar but actually or a version of it actually um this is really really misleading and because one of the astounding facts about P's grammar and part of why no one knows what century he
lived in was Pan's grammar was composed orally um so this sort of kind of blows my mind you know it's it seems you know um some of um the famous things in the west like Homer's works right the Odyssey and The Iliad right they were originally oral works that were passed down um in oral form you know you can that seems hard to do but you can kind of believe if you did plays in high school or something that someone could um memorize the Odyssey perhaps um but the idea that people could memorize a
grammar of a language passing it down for hundreds of years um kind of blows my mind um but that's exactly what happened um yeah with pines grammar um so you know really although this is sort of an old birchbark manuscript you know that really it probably dates from about a millennium after panan um composed um his grammar okay getting back to the um modern days um yeah so um for things to know yeah so I mean we don't want you to fixate on the sort of details of dependency grammar structure providing
you have the rough idea but just one thing um that you can possibly be confused about is you know there people do things in different ways one way in which they don't agree is even which way to draw the arrows so some people draw arrows um from the head pointing at the dependence and there are other people who draw the arrows starting at the dependent and pointing back at the heads um so um for modern dependency grammar um largely follows the work of um Lucien tener a French um linguist um he did the
um arrows pointing from the head to the dependent and so that's what I'm doing today but um you'll see both um we sort of said that you know normally you assume that you have a tree with a single root it's kind of common and it works out more easily for the paing if you sort of add to a sentence a sort of a fake root node so you know that that's going to be the starting point and it's going to take one dependent which is the word that's the head of the sentence and then you're going to work down from
there okay um so um before getting more into doing dependency paing I just wanted to sort of take a little detour um to tell you about the you know the importance um that happened with sort of the rise of annotated data um in natural language processing so and you know this is sort of an interesting flip slop that's occurred but we're going to sort of today go in One Direction and later class we'll go in the other direction um so in early natural language processing um people started to see oh human
languages have structure so what we should do is start writing rules for the structure of human languages and you know I start writing a few context free grammar rules for the structure of English on that early slide and you could also write dependency grammar structure rules so um people tried to do natural language processing by having rules grammar rules dictionaries of parts of speech and things like that and that gave you paes um that in retrospect worked out pretty badly and it worked out pretty badly for a number of reasons
one reason is that although there are these sort of very canonical clear structures in human languages there's a very long tale of messy stuff where all kinds of weird um usages start to emerge in human languages which sort of means you just got this it's just really hard to get coverage for handwritten language um and that's because people you humans use language creatively right so you know you can start thinking of some of the things um that you've probably come I'm probably not very good at Young
persons slang usages of grammar these days but you know um the kind of ones that you might be still familiar with right Star Wars you have Yoda talk where you rearrange the sentences but people still understand them right so that's changing the word order and earlier on than that there was sort of a uh little a bit of a f to putting not at the end of the sentences of that's a really great idea not um and well you know people um learn to understand that but it's different to regular grammar right
so it it's really hard to write a full grammar but the bigger reason actually is the problem of ambiguity I talked about right that if you just write a grammar well you know my sentence with the prepositional phrases had 13 different paes and you didn't have much reason to choose between them but you know if you had information about how often words modify other words then you could get some statistics and start to predict in which order which things modify other things and so people wanted
to start to be able to do that prediction that underlies probalistic or machine learning models and so to be able to do that that led you know sort of earliest antecedence in the 6s but really starting in the late 80s and into the '90s that people decide you the way make progress in um natural language processing natural language understanding is to build annotated data resources and so all through the '90s and the 2000s decades the name of the game for a lot of natural language processing was people building annotated
data resources and then building machine learning systems on top using those resources now that's kind of gone into reverse and gone away again with large language models which will to another week or so but here's an example so this is the universal dependencies tree Banks which I'm actually been heavily involved with and it's a cool resource for all kinds of purposes because it's actually a wide crosslinguistic um database where there's over a 100 different languages um with sentences passed with a uniform
um dependency formalism so it's actually really good for things like cross linguistic work and psychol linguistic work work but you know what these are is taking sentences I think mamar was a famous goat trainer or something um and putting a dependency structure on it it's sort of all written there sort of very squished down and human beings are producing these dependency structures and then this is giving us data that we can learn things from dependency like dependency paes from and indeed um for what you do on
homework 2 this is precisely what you'll be using is data of this sort um to build a dependency paa and it's going to learn that you know that you have goat trainers um and you have famous trainers and so it'll build up sort of statistics and information to predict what kinds of things are likely um yeah so starting off building a tree Bank like that um feels kind of like oh this is going to be slow hard work work and it is actually slow hard work um but it proved to be a very effective strategy because
it gave wonderful reusable resources that once people had done it once all sorts of people could use it to build paes part of speech taggers um to do psycholinguistic models and all kinds of things you'd get the sort of distributional frequency information that's good for machine learning it also provided one other thing that's crucial is it gave a method to evaluate systems to say how good they are at um producing paes I mean this may seem kind of comical to you in the modern era of
machine learning but the fact of the matter is when people did natural language processing in the 50s 60s 7s nobody had evaluation methods the way you showed people you had good paa is you ran the program you said type in a sentence look at what it look look it's worked it's a really good paa um you know there was no systematic valuation of NLP systems whatsoever um so actually saying look here's uh thousand hand passas sentences let's evaluate how well your paa does on those you know that was
actually a revolutionary new development um that happened in the um well end of the 80s but especially in the 90s okay um so now we going have it now that we have all of those knowledge um we're going to um want to start building dependency paes and so I'm going to um show a particular way of dependency passing which is the one you're going to use in the assignment um but you know just first off it's sort of worth just thinking for a moment you know what kind of information should a dependency paer
have to make decisions so these are kind of the four factors the sort of the obvious things that are useful for dependency passing I mean the first one is sort of thinking of the two words at the ends of the arrow as to whether they are plausible right so that for um discussion of the outstanding issues was completed um so to have um discussion of issues right that's that's a plausible dependency um to have um you know what's the silly one to have something like um the being a dependent of completed that
makes no sense at all so you know what words there are involved um the second one is dependency distance so you can have longdistance dependencies that go a long way but most dependenc sees are short distance you know a lot of words are depending on their neighboring words at a very short distance so that's a good preference to have um as well as just the distance it's somewhat informative knowing what's in between so it's rare for dependencies to span verbs or punctuation um and then there's a final
one which is to think of the veency of heads and that's how many arguments um they take so that if you have sort of something like a verb broke um well it probably has something um to the left because it probably has who did the breaking and it probably has something to the right um cuz there might be the cup or something like that um but you know it doesn't have to be that cuz it could be the cup broke um so you can have something to the left but nothing to the right but you sort of have to have something to the left and
conversly you can't have any number of things you can't sort of just say he broke the cup the sorcer um the dish um right so it doesn't take just lots of arguments to the left so we've got a notion of veency like that um yeah there's one other tricky little notion on dependency paring which is normally um normally dependencies kind of Nest like this um and nesting dependencies corresponds to a tree structure as you'd have in a context free grammar [Music] yeah because in a sense when I read the
sentence which I thought that the most important discussion [Music] so so I will fair enough I will assert that this is uh sentence and discussion is the subject of the verb completed and you know normally for a sentence we say the main thing in the sentence is its verb and so yeah so that's why the root is heading to completed and the subject of the verb is also an important thing but the arguments of the verb like the subject of the verb the object of the verb if there is one prepositional phrase
modifiers they're all taken as dependence of the verb yeah up on that is it is it not the that you start with so um if you have a sentence with a verb like this um it's always that is always the answer I mean some of the details here depend on languages but there are languages in which you don't have to have a verb in a sentence um and you can get things like um um just I mean you can do it in sort of very restricted ways in in in English right so if you just sort of say easy as pie um there's no verb and so then
you're saying easy um the adjective which is sort of the predicate adjective is then the head of the sentence sorry like a question like what is the story is the is like we would still look at that as the that is complicated some people would say it is um and some people would say it isn't um and particular in Universal dependencies we don't actually say that is is the head of the sentence but I don't want to get too far into this if you want you could sort of look more at how things are done
but you know I want to fully admit that you know dependency grammar isn't sort of one uniquely defined Theory people have had different ideas of which things to take as the head in various circumstances and they argue about it linguists argue about what the right structure is to put over all sorts of sentences but that the fact that people do things different ways doesn't mean that everybody doesn't agree that there are units there are phrases and modifiers and ambiguities and so on
between them okay um yeah so normally we get this sort of nesting that corresponds to what you can build with context free grammar structure but sometimes in human languages you get dependencies that don't Nest so you get sentences like I'll give a talk tomorrow on new networks where actually the on new networks is modifying the talk where the yesterday um is an argument of sorry the tomorrow is an argument of give and so you get these Crossing dependencies which are referred to as non-projective
dependencies um you also get them when you form questions so who did Bill buy the coffee from yesterday that the who is the object of the preposition from but it's been moved out the front and so that again um gives us non-projective um if you think about it um yeah you can still say um that you have a dependency tree but it's got the words in different orders and so one of the things that you have to cope with for full dependency PA is dealing with this non projectivity but I mean actually we're not going to
deal with it in our paes we're only going to do um projective dependency paing okay so there are various ways that people do dependency paring people have done it by dynamic programming people who've done it using graph algorithms if I have enough time at the end I might mention that again people have done it with constraint satisfaction methods if you saw those in cs220 21 um but the most common way in practice that's emerged um has been this transition based paing um which is kind
of sort of interesting as well and gives the sort of a very simple machine learning mechanism um so it makes it good for um assignment two and so that's what we're going to explore here okay so um what we do um in Greedy decision based paing in transition based paing is you know this is where it's unfortunate that only two people in the class have done a compiler's class um so um so a simple form of passing that's also used in compilers classes something called shift reduced paing where you start sort of
bottom up and you start putting little units together and build bigger constituents but um if most people have hav't seen it that's not going to be um very much um help so I'm going to give you a concrete example so the things to know is we' have two data structure well we have more than two I guess um for dealing with the sentence we have two data structures we have a buffer which has the words of our input sentence and then we start building pieces of um sentence structure which we put on a
stack and a little trick to know is for the buffer the the top is written to the left and for the stack the top is written to the right um and so we take actions which are like shift and reduce actions and when we take ARC building actions we build up a set of dependency arcs which are going to be the dependency structure of our sentence and that's all incredibly abstract um and so I'm going to show an example um which hopefully will a bit give the idea um so here's an example so I want to do
this very um simple example um of passing up the sentence I ate fish um so I so the way I do this is I have my stack and so I start by putting the root symbol on my stack and then I have in my buffer all the words of the sentence and so that's the sort of start condition I've written and very small print there then for each step of processing I have a choice of three operations I can either shift which moves the top word on the buffer onto the stack or I can do left Arc or right Arc and these are my
two reduce operations that build a little bit of syntactic structure by saying that one word is a dependent of another word in either a left or a right direction so here a sequence of operations I can take and um so starting off the first thing I can do is shift so then I've moved I onto the stack um I can decide that I want to shift again and so then I'd take eight and also move it onto the stack and so I've now got three things on my stack so at this point you know I can do other things I mean in particular a left
Arc is going to say well I can take the top two things on the stack and make the uh the thing on the top The Head and the thing one down on the stack a dependent of it so if I do a left Arc operation I'm effectively saying that the I is a dependent of eight and then I pop both of then I pop the dependent off the stack back but I add on that I've built um a dependency that I made I a dependent of eight I could then do another shift operation so I shift fish um from the buffer onto the stack and
then I can do a right Arc which says um okay I'm going to have fish as a dependent of eight so then fish disappears from the stack and I add in this new dependency saying fishes dependent of eight um I then do right Arc again um which is then saying that um eight is a dependent of root so I'm left with just root on my stack and I've built a new dependent saying eight is a dependent of root and at this point I've gone to the finishing condition my finishing condition is that my buffer is
empty and my um stack contains just the word root um and so this gives me a little step set of operations referred to as the transitions of transition-based passing and by making a sequence of these different transitions I can build sentence structure and I've got choices of when to shift and when to reduce and whether to reduce left or reduce right the arc left Arc right and so by making different ones of those choices I could make any structure for the sentence that I wanted to so you know if I somehow thought that this
sentence should have a different structure and that I should be the head and eights are dependent of that and fishes are dependent of that well I could achieve this by making some different choices as to I'd now be saying I was doing a right Arc operation so that eight would become a dependent of I rather than the other way around so the choices of which oper operations I take determine the syntactic structure the set of dependencies that I have built um which are my set of dependencies down here now the center of
dependencies I built were exactly the right ones because at each step I took the right operation um and so the essential um idea of um transition based paing and where it came to the four was um there was a particular guy who's I've got a photo of him in somewhere in a bit I thought um so yoram Nea um is a Swedish NLP person um and in the early 2000s um he came up with the idea of um rather than doing the kind of dynamic programming and chart paing and things that people commonly used to do with
PES these days we have machine Lear learning so maybe we could build a fast efficient paa and the way we're going to build it is with this making a sequence of Transitions and it'll be the job of the machine learning to predict what is the right transition at each point in time so if you do that you know at each point you're dealing with one thing and so the number of operations you're doing to pass a sentence is linear so this gives a linear time passing algorithm whereas if um you've seen context free
grammars and stuff like that in CS 103 and you want to do anything where you're fully considering the paes and structures of context free grammars you've then got a cubic time algorithm which is much less Pleasant to be dealing with um so for the simplest form of transition-based paing you do no search whatsoever at each step you're just predicting the next transition and so you're doing this sort of sequence of transition predictions as machine learning operations and that sequence
gives you the path structure of the sentence and the essential result that Neo is able to show is that machine learning um is good enough that you can do this and get a very accurate paraa despite the fact that it no search whatsoever is just doing predictions in this way okay um so how did so when he did in 2005 that was before neural networks came to the four and so the way he was doing it was by using a sort of an older style um symbolic feature based um machine Learning System so he had a big
classifier which might have been a list istic regression classifier or something else like a support Vector machine and so to power that he was using indicator features so the kind of features you'd use is that the word on the top of the stack is the word good and it's part of speech as an adjective or um the word um on the top of the stack is good but the word that's sort of second on the stack is the verb had right you'd get these sort of combinations of matching functions and
they would be used as features in a machine Learning System to predict the pars um but the problem is that once you started building these features that were conjunctions of multiple terms you ended up with millions and millions of features right because you putting particular words and features um and then you're combining choices of multiple words so they're just millions and millions of features so had to deal with millions and millions of features and furthermore individual features were
exceedingly sparse that you barely ever saw them right that you'd have a feature that only turned up you know 10 times in a million sentences because they are matching these very precise systems so on the one hand um by making these feature conjunctions paing got more accurate and indeed people produced pretty accurate paes in those days but they had sort of these unappealing characteristics of this sort um yeah so uh before going on further I should just explain how we evaluate dependency paes um so um to
evaluate dependency paes we're basically assessing are you getting the dependency arcs arrows your proposing right um so here is someone's dependency PA she saw the video lecture um well actually sorry that's the gold pa okay that's a correct pa okay she saw the video lecture that's a correct PA so you can write out what are um the the different dependencies right so one's head is two two's head is zero word three's head is five words Four's head is five word
five's head is two so these pairs of numbers represent our dependencies then if someone proposes a PA of the sentence you can literally say okay which of these did they get right so they didn't get this one right um they got the rest of them right so they accuracy is 80% and so sometimes people just assess the arcs unlabeled and so that's referred to as unlabeled dependency accuracy but sometimes people also want to label them with with um subject determiner object Etc and say also are you getting the
labels right so in this case only two of the five labels are right so the labeled accuracy of the dependency passes is 40% okay um so so that was sort of what people did um until the mid 2010s um and and I sort of already started saying this the problems with indicator features were they were sparse you didn't see them often they were incomplete because there's some words and combinations you've seen and some you just didn't see in the training data so you're missing features um but
the final problem is actually just Computing all those um symbolic features was just expensive it turns out that if you did runtime analysis most of time in the paing wasn't in doing the machine learning decisions it was just simply in Computing the features that you put into this dependency paa so as new net started to um show that they were successful for things that suggested that maybe you could build um a better dependency paa by using a newal net um transition-based dependency paa which
would benefit from the kind of dens and compact um feature Vector representations that we've already started to see um and so that's um what started to be explored and in particular who was then a PhD student of mine um and was head TA of 224n twice actually in the earlier days um so um she built um uh neural transition-based dependency paa um and showed the success of this method um so this was um nea's transition-based dependency paa um people had also explored other methods of dependency
passing so these were two graph-based dependency paes and essentially um for the kind of um symbolic feature machine learning methods um NE paa was really fast because I was using this linear trans um transition based paing idea that depend the graph-based dependency paes were way way slower right you know they're about what 50 times slower um but they were slightly more accurate you can see here that you're getting a bit better numbers so essentially what was able to show was um you could build
something that was basically as accurate as the best known um graph-based dependency pases but it was fast like other um transition based fases indeed despite the fact that it's you might think that oh now I've got real numbers and matrices and stuff surely that should be slowing me down the reality was that the symbolic models spent so much time in feature um computation that actually you could make it faster at the same time by using a newal network okay so how did that work um well so we've already seen word
embedding so it's going to exploit word embed so it can use word representations and that has the advantage that even if you haven't seen particular words and particular configurations you've seen similar words and so it can exploit what's likely in terms of word similarity but it went a bit further than that because why only have distributed representations of words we also have parts of speech and although I sort of said just noun verb adjective most actual systems in NLP of parts of
speech are much more fine grained so they have different parts of speech for plural nouns versus singular nouns so they're sort of different symbols but they're very similar to each other so we might give them distributed representation so they're also close to each other and the same for the types of our labels for dependencies some of them are pretty closely related as well so all of these were being given distributed representations and so then to represent the state of the dependency paa for
predicting transitions what you were doing is you had the same kind of stack and buffer and you are taking the key elements of the stack and the buffer which are essentially the first thing on the buffer the word that you would be shifting if you're going to do a shift and the two things at the top of the stack so these are the things that if you're either doing a left Arc or a right Arc they're things that you're considering combining so for those you're going to be taking the
distributed representations of the word and their parts of speech and also with a bit more complexity um for dependencies you've already constructed if maybe something on the stack is already involved in a dependency each of those we're going to take their distributed representations and we're going to just concatenate them together to produce a big um Vector in the same way were concatenating together the five words in the last class for predicting whether something was the location or
not and then we're going to feed that um into our neural network so um we our input layer is our concatenate distributed representations we're going to put that through a hidden layer which is like we were talking about last time WX plus b then put through a relue nonlinearity and then we're going to put above that the same kind of um another multiply by a matri so we've got a second layer of neural network uh plus B2 and we're going to take the output of that and then we're going to put that
through a soft Max that gives a probability distribution over whether to um shift or do a left Arc or a right Arc operation and so the other way that this crucially gave us more power is that other people's dependency paes were still using linear classifiers things like support Vector machines or logistic regressions where we had a deep neural network that gave us a nonlinear classifier but and so that's why we could be more accurate than other um previous um transition based paes and so
this um essentially um showed that you could build this very accurate neural dependency paa and that it outperformed um symbolic um probalistic representations and basically was as good as any other dependency paa that was known so um back a decade to go um this was a big hit um people got very excited about it um the people at Google got very excited about it because this gave a um a scalable way remember it's linear time in which you could efficiently go of and pass um the entire web um so they did um some further work
on taking that model and proving it so that they um made an a deeper neural network version with bigger vectors and better tuned hyperparameters and they added on to a beam search I've just presented the greedy version where you always CH just immediately make the best choice but you can improve these paas by doing some amount of search that does help um and so um they pushed that up and so rather than our kind of 92 uas here they got it to you know 94 94.6 and I mean um you're uh you're probably um all too
young to remember this but um you know really at the time of 2016 you know Google did their kind of typical big PR PR Splash for dependency parza which kind of blew my mind since I didn't ever think that anyone was really going to be writing articles in W and Venture beat and those kind of tech um blogs but you know Google had it all over the place of the world's most accurate paa and they gave it a silly name pzy mpas face which really worked well um for getting lots of media pickup um and so that was then um a very
successful paa um I've still got a couple of minutes left so let me just um do the last um three slides to show you sort of another way of doing things which is also actually also a powerful paing method that is commonly used so um that was transition-based paing and that's what you'll use an assignment to another way of doing things with dependencies and paing can be done neural is what's referred to as graph-based dependency paes and in graph-based dependency paes what you do is um for each word you sort
of ask for each word what am I a dependent of right so if the sentence is the big cat sat each word for example big has to be a dependent of one of the other four words in this sentence including this possibility of root so we ask am I dependent of that am I dependent of root am I dependent of cat am I dependent of sat and we want to score each of those possibilities and so hopefully we decide the most likely one is the Bigg as a dependent of cat and then we're going to do the same for every other word so you know sat could
be a dependent of any of these words and so we could start asking okay which of these words is it most likely a dependent of uh beat to sat cat to sat um sorry that's unreadable now but hopefully we decide um that sat most likely as the verb is a dependent of root so we sort of scoring the N squared possible you know dependencies of the sentence and each one is given a score and then once we've done that our job is let me go to this one cleaner okay we've decided the good one there and so we we're going to
do this using some of the same features we talked about looking at the words at each end looking at what occurs between them looking at what occurs around them um thinking about um things um and then once we've done that the only other thing that's a constraint is well we want the dependencies to form a tree um so that we need to do um something like a minimum spanning tree algorithm to sort of find the minimum cost tree because we don't want to find a solution where there are Cycles or the parts of
the sentence end up disconnected with each other um and so that's graph-based dependency paes and so just as in the older symbolic paing days where the graph based dependency paes were more accurate than the transition based paes um that we then started doing some work on neural graph based depend dependency paring and so here's our neurog graph based dependency paring um which was then a bit over a percent more accurate than pzy mpaz face the world's best um dependency paer um so um so that got us
to 2017 I mean obviously this is still a few years ago but to get further into the latest um paring Stories We then need to sort of get into the ER of large language models which I'm not doing today um but it's this neural graph based dependency paa um that's in um stanza our open- source um paing software that's available and that you can see it's using this algorithm as the more accurate one okay so now you hopefully know everything about syntactic structure constituency independency paing and are fully
qualified to do assignment to so good luck with that thanks